hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to lose back fat okay now
that's actually three problems number
one we have a problem with insulin if
you've been watching my other videos
insulin is the hormone that makes the
muffin top and it can extend around the
back so that's one point and then
cortisol cortisol is a stress hormone
course Oh does release insulin that's
from stress and that will also cause
them up on top around the waist but the
other one that's really common is actual
atrophy of your muscles in your back a
lot of people neglect the back muscles
simply because they don't see their back
they see the front so they're doing the
sit-ups and the ab workouts but the back
is it's just as important so there's
some really key things to strengthen
them back and also tone it to make sure
we get rid of the atrophy is to really
get rid of that back fat so number one
how do we get rid of insulin there's
there's three it's called the three
essence okay number one snacking you
have to stop snacking snacking increases
insulin and so does any eating so you
really want to do intermittent fasting
which is like eat and then don't eat for
a while and then eat and don't eat okay
so this whole grazing thing five six
small meals for the day is really bad
advice so we want to do snacking we want
to avoid snacking at all cost and just
eat three meals if you want to eat and
go from one meal to the next add a
little bit of healthy fat to go be able
to go on further but that will put you
in a fat-burning state which you will
actually then run on your body on what's
called ketones and not glucose and
you'll lower the need for insulin so
this is really important number two of
course the obvious avoid sugar I don't
need to tell you that but you probably
already know that and that's all the
hidden sugars bread pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes
muffins sodas juice and that does
include alcohol yogurt because it has 10
grams of sugar and of course the juice
so that's really we need to avoid that
too lower insulin and then we want to
spike our greens why because greens have
potassium potassium will decrease the
need for insulin in fact insulin
and potassium work really closely
together and if you can actually
increase your potassium you will lower
the need for insulin and also if you
actually fix the insulin but you'll
actually start absorbing more potassium
too so they work really closely and it
has to do with the cell and the little
potassium sodium pumps that are on there
and also the receptors in the cells I'm
not going to get into that but if you do
spike your greens you will actually
improve that okay that means bigger
salads you can do wheatgrass juice
powder that that type of thing as well
all right now let's talk about cortisol
cortisol is a stress hormone the way you
know you have core cells you are under
stress your tolerance for stress is low
people get on your nerves easily you you
don't sleep that well you got the belly
fat and it wraps around so one of the
best thing is get rid of kind of three
main stresses first of all the body
stress your body is like a sponge it
holds stress it accumulates stress over
time time does not heal stress okay all
the old injuries old infections just
being in a stress State your body kind
of breaks down so what you want there's
a physical technique so I'm going to put
pulling up the picture right now all
that being done and you can do it on
your neck you can do it in different
parts of your body but it's a stress
extraction technique using a massage
tool that I developed that so you can
use that to remove body stress so every
night that you go to sleep you can make
sure you never go to sleep stressed but
stress-free so fit mechanically we want
to release the points the epicenters of
all the stress in your body okay that's
one number two people stress okay I know
you know this but out of all the things
that stress people out our people okay
mainly you know antagonist to people
people that bring you down so what I
like to do is I like to really look in
my environment
who is stressing me out the most and
either avoid that person or deal with
them or improve the situation there also
could be stress from watching evening TV
the news so don't watch the news it's
just recycled sensation back over and
over they're taking this one point
trying to come different spin at
different ways different angles
it's okay to get the news that just make
sure you don't keep watching that same
point over and over and over and then
you also have the nutritional factors
okay there are two main nutrients that
will help lower cortisol number one is
violent b1 very very important because
when you're under stress you deplete
vitamin b1 b1 releases stress it makes
you feel calm it increases your
tolerance for stress and a lot of people
are deficient in b1 and it's because
they're doing so many grains and refined
sugars but the best source of the one
would be nutritional yeast take a
teaspoon a day now like within about a
minute you'll just feel the difference
it's like quite dramatic and then of
course the next one to be potassium
potassium is good for lowering insulin
and cortisol that comes from a lot of
different greens that you can have
vegetables that type of thing but that
you cannot lower potato so just by doing
a high protein diet or anything like
that you need to add the greens because
potassium is the physiological
tranquilizer it's a calming mineral just
like calcium but potassium you need so
much more in most people are deficient
okay those are the those that's like one
and two now number three or as far as
the exercise goes now there's basically
four exercise that I'm going to
recommend the first one deals with the
extensors in the glutes I mean if you
think about it people are doing sit-ups
right they're doing situps to get rid of
their stomach
but they don't reverse the flow so what
is this the stomach its flexor muscles
that muscles that flex you so we want to
do the opposite muscles we want to work
on the extensors what are the extensors
the glutes ok the glutes are the
extensors and also part of your back
muscles so what you're going to do is
you're going to lay get on your all
fours and you're gonna start doing these
extensions and I'm actually showing you
a demo right now how to do that so you
want to do that probably do is I would
actually not necessarily just do sets I
would do it as long as you can be feel
you get fatigued
rest for about three or four minutes do
it again until you get fatigued like
majorly fatigued
and then do another cycle because you
might be able to do 25 you might be able
to do 35 you might be able to do 7 so
that's a good way to judge to see how
you're doing ok now the next one is
called the side push-up where you're on
your side and you're actually really
working your core from a different angle
so when you do this exercise you're
working something called obliques the
side muscles that wrap around and it's a
great it's an emotion that a lot of
people do not even consider they can do
or they've never really workout they
work just on one to one dimension sit
upright so this gives it another
dimension this will really help toned
waist kay the third one it's called the
side position and hold that's the one
where you just get on your side and you
hold it as long as you can and then you
can go to the other opposite side as
long as you can go back and forth I
would do three cycles and I'd probably
do that every other day this one is good
because it helps you create stability
it's kind of like a yoga move but it
actually builds up your core which is
your midsection now the last one is
called the back arch this is just a
straight reversal of the sit-up it's
really good for low back pain and it's
really good for people that do too many
sit-ups you lay in your stomach and you
arch back and again you're gonna be
probably for this one you'll probably do
sets of maybe 12 to 15 three sets of
that make sure you rest maybe four
minutes in between but what you want to
do is you really want to work that back
get the tone back we're not necessarily
burning calories for this we're getting
the muscles to be more toned to get to
develop the back muscles because that is
an area that so many people never even
work those muscles so they just start
fall apart all right go ahead and apply
this information and I will see you in
the next video